well the Trump administration was very
close to launching major military
strikes on the nation of Iran last week
at the very last minute though the
president pulled back and thank goodness
he did instead of being praised for the
best decisions he's made so far as
president Trump has come under attack
for that on the right radio show host
Hugh Hewitt accused the president of
being a weakling for not launching a
trillion dollar war over a broken robot
listen let's go to what the president
did yesterday I've been very critical of
it this morning I call it a u-turn the
redline Redux I think that it's very
important for all of our decision makers
to recognize that weakness is
provocative and that you know a world in
which responds to attacks on American
assets is to pull back or to accept the
attack is a world in which America won't
be able to successfully defend our
interests so Iran's going to invade New
Jersey because we haven't started a war
with them all right
Democratic presidential candidates
meanwhile have denounced the president
also see how but they have try to follow
the reasoning from the very beginning of
his presidency taking a belligerent
course of escalation and provocation
with Iran I mean we pulled out of a anti
nuclear deal that gave us complete
transparency into their nuclear program
it's like somebody setting a fire to a
basket full of paper and then putting it
out he helped create the crisis and then
he stopped the attacks there is no
question in my mind that the current
occupant of the White House was
president Trump put in place a series of
events that led to that event
yeah that's Kelly Harris's position if
you can't understand what it is she
can't so it isn't Trump though is eager
to start a war with country after
country it's the rest of official
Washington obviously starting with the
National Security Advisor John Bolton
the President himself pointed that out
believe it or not on Meet the Press over
the weekend watch this I have two groups
of people I have doves and AB Hawks
you have some some hawks yeah yeah John
Bolton is absolutely a hawk is up to him
he'd take on the whole world at one time
okay presidents aren't typically that
straightforward and honest he's a liar
well okay you certainly ought us there